No hello and welcome to this video
playing Allah gasps yeah what is he
doing what did I do in the recent games
I played c14 yeah played more c4 against
them I can still probably get down
because it plays quite reliably the same
systems yeah I'm also in quite ok with
those with those lines him
let's see what he does Ruby aids Bishop
d6 I don't quite remember the theory
myself there should be 6 as the main
wolf I think I'd like to play 5 ok he
did not play Bishop system which is
possible and this this position is a
little bit more comfortable for ride
usually I try to get the nitrous e4
probably will gain the temple because of
that repeal that is fork
I mean okay no because of the for
Pattaya
because I attacked the Queen okay so
here I can also go Knight g5 it's also a
good move and go to you for it's not
necessary but it's not bad I could have
taken with a pawn should and I was I
played this too quickly taking with the
porn was pretty strong actually I mean
this is not bad but I could have taken
with the pawn it would have been would
have been stronger either
this is of course also better for Wyatt
but I think the alternative was even
more promising okay so it's so difficult
to get something real here I think I
will will take the pawn difficult to
convert down so yeah this is always
under fire probably have to cover this I
want Bishop b3 and Bishop d2 level 10
p.m. so okay that's a good defense well
okay that was a good maneuver that was a
good maneuver that you played
okay
maybe we'll give one 1952 this kind of
idea I should have found done that
before so only non-ghosts for check
[Music]
what ticks with the pawn okay it's
probably good idea actually King on g6
and then it's a draw can I do something
at least probably not
[Music]
[Music]
I have almost no chance at all to do
anything here yeah I can
I just cannot uncut the King away you're
from g6
[Music]
okay just a draw which is not enough but
so what it is the anything that I can
try I can play on time like he usually
does it's kind of a funny idea I'm a
little bit quicker you can probably just
check just press yeah
press the little button wrong I don't
really like to do this kind of stuff and
that was just - mm you played this just
terribly actually tear pawn takes was a
lot stronger that is that is already
very critical for back so Candace this
is also just eternally better for Wyatt
with my better structure but I didn't
didn't manage to Windows which is really
disappointing I lost some some time with
with this key one yeah I should get more
I mean I always have this form but it's
probably almost impossible to win yeah
maybe we'll get see fine okay in order
to win I probably should keep the rooks
on the board but I think the likelihood
of the draw is extremely high
yeah okay guys thanks for watching
you